(audience clapping)
- All right, we also
have another actress here
from the cast of "The Thing About Pam",
which you can see Tuesdays on NBC.
She was supposed to tape her
interview with us earlier,
but got stuck in a snowstorm,
which I have been stuck in a snowstorm
and it sucks.
She's a two-time Oscar winner
who hails from the best
state in the union, y'all.
That's right, we're annoying.
Texas.
That's right.
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)
Please welcome fellow Texas
girl, Renée Zellweger! (claps)
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
- Hi, y'all!
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] It's nice to see-
- Hi.
- [Kelly] Oh, you look so beautiful.
- Thank you. So do you, ma'am.
- [Kelly] I love this
whole Audrey Hepburn look.
- Oh, thanks so much.
- How are you doing?
I've been stuck in a snowstorm before
(Renee laughs)
and without much.
- [Renée] You know?
- Yeah, Yeah.
- And there's not a lot you can do.
You just kinda have to resign to it.
There's not a lot you can do.
- So how far did you make it
till you had to pull over?
- Well, I was just outside of Bakersfield.
I'd come down from Davis,
there's this great
veterinarian hospital up there.
That's where my fella goes
to get his hip surgeries
and whatnot.
He just got outta surgery now, actually.
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
- So, I know, fingers crossed.
I just got word he has a herniated disc-
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- it seems.
- Me too.
In my neck.
- Right? (laughs)
- Yeah.
- I know a really good surgeon. (laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
So, yeah, so Bakersfield,
and you just see all the
18 wheelers pulling over
into the right-hand lanes
and it was bumper to bumper for miles.
You could see what was going on.
The maps, and the Waze, and the
maps and they try to divert.
They're like, "Okay, go, you know
take this alternative route."
And it was heading into
the mountains. (laughs)
- And you were like, wrong turn. (laughs)
- In my rented minivan and a T-shirt
and I'm like, "Nah."
- My rented minivan.
- Nah.
- And a T-shirt. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- Oh my god, I love that.
It's always good to
have a Texas girl here,
but you're from, not Houston, is it Katy?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
A couple of my band
members are from Beaumont,
that whole area.
- Oh, yeah, sure.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I actually went to elementary school
on the east side of there near Beaumont,
so I got over there.
- [Kelly] Oh, right on.
- [Renée] Yeah.
- Do you get back there often?
- The last time I was there, I think...
I drive through a lot, you know?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I'll drive out to Austin,
I like to road trip,
and I'll head down occasionally.
I went to my fifth grade
teacher's retirement
a couple years ago, Mr. Matson, and-
- Oh my god, I love that.
- Yeah, he became the
high school librarian,
so he was with us until my class,
till we graduated, and, yeah,
- That's cool.
- I couldn't recognize my town.
It grew so much.
It was crazy.
- Oh my gosh, me too.
- Yeah?
I left and I came back.
It was just like even a few years later,
and I was like, "This
is like a metropolis."
- [Renee] Yeah, it's crazy.
- Like, what?
We had, like, a Walmart.
- There's overpasses.
- That was all we had
(Renee laughs)
when I was here.
- What happened?
- Yeah.
- We got a mall.
- You got real cool when I left.
(Kelly laughs)
I was like, "Whatever."
What's the hardest part though for you
for getting used to LA?
Mine is traffic.
- Oh, interesting.
Okay, it was that crosswalk.
You know the crosswalk where...
'Cause usually if somebody
stops in the left lane,
it's 'cause they're gonna turn left,
and so you'll go around them.
But no, no, in LA it's
because there's a human.
(both laugh)
There's a human in the road
and you have to learn not
to go around the person.
- [Kelly] To not hit the pedestrians.
- Correct, don't kill anybody.
That was the big part.
- That's a good lesson.
- Don't kill anybody.
That and the billboards.
Do you remember that,
when you got to town?
The enormity of them?
You drive down Sunset Boulevard.
Now I'm sure anybody who's visiting,
it's remarkable, isn't it?
- It's kind of overwhelming though.
- It is, they're all layered.
It looks kind of like it's-
- Yeah, I literally, when I
moved here after high school,
I was like 18 when I moved here,
and it was right after high school,
and I remember going on Sunset,
and I was like,
there was almost too much happening.
I couldn't.
And then I'm like, "How do
people not wreck daily here
just looking at everything?"
- Yeah, 'cause it's a stimuli.
- Yeah.
- A stimuli.
- Yeah, it's a lot.
- Yeah, it's overwhelming.
It's true,
and it feels like, it's almost
like, there's so much noise
that they gotta get bigger, and louder,
and bigger, and louder,
and nobody notices it
at all, or something.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I don't know.
- And do you want them to notice it
while they're behind the wheel?
I don't know.
- Yeah, there's that too.
- Then there's that part.
- I don't know.
Do you remember though,
the first time your
face was on a billboard?
(Renée laughs)
'Cause that's fun.
I remember mine, it was like
a radio station, I think.
They put my face with another artist,
or whatever for a radio station.
I was like, "My face is on a giant board."
I was like, "I have made it."
- I remember the first time
your face was on a giant board.
(both laugh)
- Do you remember your first?
- A lot of us remember the first time
your face was on a giant board. (claps)
(audience clapping)
- Aww, you're so nice.
- I was so happy for you.
- I just thought
it was really cool.
I was like, "Wow."
I dunno why they wanted me
up there, but it happened.
- Well we know why. (laughs)
- Wait, what Was your experience like?
Do you remember?
- Well, I just remember that
I had a lot of films come out,
a bunch of films come out,
and they didn't need me to
be on the billboard (laughs).
- Oh my God, so it's like
the other person's on the-
- I barely made the movie.
- Oh my gosh.
- I barely made the movie, so-
- Well look at you now.
- They didn't need me on the billboard.
(audience clapping)
- Okay, okay.
- How sweet.
- Do you, whenever, I know
you said you go to Austin,
do you miss Texas food?
I love Texas food.
- It's funny, when I make
my plans with my friends,
it's always around where
we're gonna eat. (laughs)
- Why not? Absolutely.
- How many times we could cram tacos
into the schedule,
that's basically-
- Yes, 'cause it's Tex-Mex.
- 'Cause it's Tex-Mex.
- Yes, It's different than here.
So when I moved here,
I was like, "What is this Mexican food?"
It's probably authentic Mexican food.
- Why is there mango in my salsa? (laughs)
- I know.
I was like, "Why? Why?
And there's strawberries,
is that new for guac?
Okay, cool."
- And why is my iced tea
passion fruit? Like what?
- [Kelly] Yeah, I just want a normal one.
- I just want a lemon.
- Yeah, I love Tex-Mex, so
that's my favorite thing.
And I thought that
maybe you might miss it.
- I do miss-
So I brought you something.
- [Renée] What?
- Okay, here we go.
- What?
- I'm a polite host
(audience clapping)
I'm a polite host.
(audience cheering)
You have a drink
and some queso.
- [Renée] I dunno.
- Okay, no, no, wait.
- You're gonna have to
wrap this up. (laughs)
- Hold on, sit down for a minute, wait.
'Cause here's the thing.
I have been...
This is season three.
Since season one, I have been searching
for good queso in LA.
- [Renée] Okay.
This queso is from Roadside Taco,
right here in Studio City.
- Oh, very nice.
- Shout out because it's awesome.
- Okay.
- I'm not even being paid by them,
I just really love this queso.
- It does look good, Roadside.
- But I need you to like,
maybe, do you want a taste?
- No, no, I'm in.
- Okay, We have our own.
- I'm so in.
- We have our own.
- Is this mean?
'Cause everybody's leaning
forward over there.
Is this mean?
- I don't know,
but my mouth is watering,
and I'm so excited.
- I know, I'm a little happy about it.
- Oh you guys, I'd like
to apologize in advance,
'cause these look really good.
(audience laughing)
- It's good.
It needs to be warmed up a tiny bit,
but whatever, it's really good.
- I mean.
- But I like it when
it's warmed up heavily,
it's really runny, that's what I love.
- You know what?
- And a margarita.
- I think it's better than that.
My head might blow off.
It is so good.
- I know, it's so hard to
find good queso here, but-
- Thank you, cheers.
- Cheers.
- Oh, I drank before, that's rude.
(audience clapping)
Oh, I like your ring.
- Ladies and gentlemen, Kelly Clarkson.
Thank you, what a sweet thing to do.
- Congrats on this series.
So this was actually inspired
by a Dateline episode, right?
- Yeah, it is.
It's based on the Dateline episode
and the subsequent podcast,
which I actually listened to
on the 5 freeway, driving Chester the dog
up to get his hip surgery. (laughs)
- [Kelly] His name is Chester?
- His name is Chester.
- Oh, my dog's name is Henry.
- Oh see.
- I feel like they'd be friends.
- Chester doesn't really
have friendly manners.
- You know what?
Neither does...
Henry doesn't have dog friends either.
(Renée laughs)
- Yeah, he doesn't.
- I wish.
- I know.
- I wish, no, I don't know what it is.
He just thinks that they
either make good snacks,
(Kelly laughs)
or like that they're really da- you know?
- Yeah.
- He's gotta protect me
from all the dogs in the world.
So, you know-
- I love that.
- He's like a, yeah, I know, but-
So you would listen to the podcast?
- Oh, yeah, I listened to the podcast,
and I binged it,
and there wasn't even a snowstorm.
I crammed it in there
on the way up to Davis,
and I thought, "Wow,
that's really interesting."
'Cause you start listening to the story.
It revolves around the case
of the murder of Betsy Faria in 2011.
And you just start to ask questions,
like how did this happen?
and how did her husband get convicted
when there was so much evidence
that made you scratch your head about it?
- Yeah.
- And it just seemed
like something that would be
really interesting to explore.
- Yeah, it's a crazy story.
- It's a crazy story.
- Yes, and is it fun to get
to play a part like that?
- Well-
- Or do you take some of it home?
Like when you go in
that character? (laughs)
- Oh no. (laughs)
- Yeah, you're like, "No,
but ask others." (laughs)
- Yeah, right.
No, I like the research, you know?
- Yeah.
- Because there's something about it
that's compelling, something about it
that's difficult to understand,
and putting the pieces together,
to try to paint a picture that
makes it a little bit more,
that makes it makes sense,
is what's interesting to me.
And so, lots of studying
about human behavior,
and what motivates people
to do certain things,
and just like that.
- Yeah.
So wait, how much do you lose of yourself
in these characters?
'Cause I've heard it's
one of my favorite things.
I think it was Sting.
I might be not saying this right.
But whenever he goes
into writing like music,
it's hard to get out of it.
You get so into it.
You wanna make the record great.
You wanna make the song great.
And it's hard to kind of
climb out, like emotionally.
Do you ever do that with characters?
- Well, not on purpose, you know?
- Yeah.
- It's just that you take
on all of this information,
and you're processing it and living it.
You're living in it all the time
and then reenacting it during the day.
Go home, you read and take in some more.
So, yeah, it becomes part of...
It becomes a really
big part of your focus,
your daily focus.
- [Kelly] For that moment.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's weird.
- Yeah, when you hear
the voice, and all the
sayings, all the time.
So not, yeah,
(Kelly laughs)
the character's voice from recordings.
Not like-
- You hear voices, and everything's fine.
(both laugh)
- So wait, was becoming Pam more difficult
than becoming Judy Garland,
or less intimidating?
I don't know, which one was?
I feel like it would be
intimidating to play Judy Garland.
- [Renée] Wow. That's-
- [Kelly] You nailed it.
- [Renée] Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- Yeah, but I just mean
that would be intimidating.
(audience clapping)
- Yeah, I try to remove
myself from the reality of it,
which is that you're creating something
that folks are gonna see,
and I just kind of go-
- Dive in.
- Yeah, that's it.
Just dive into it and do the work.
So I just get really involved in the work,
and it becomes about that,
so I don't think about anything else.
I'm just curious.
- [Kelly] That's smart.
- I got from that perspective.
- But this was, it was hotter.
It was hotter to play.
(Kelly laughs)
- I was miserable.
- That stuff.
- It was hot.
No, there was a lot of comedy involved,
'cause you gotta laugh your
way through stuff like that.
But I'd never worked with full prosthetics
like that before.
And it's a skill that I didn't know
that I did not have. (laughs)
- That I was not excited about.
- I did not know.
It was fun to learn, you know?
But it's fun on the first day,
when you go, "Oh wait." (laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's a lot.
- Wait, I can't, I'm smiling,
but you can't tell. (laughs)
- Yeah, oh my God, like acting
in that's such a hard thing.
Oh my gosh, I never thought about that.
- You gotta move these
things and you have to...
Yeah, but Arian, he's a genius.
- Yeah.
- And yeah, he's really cool.
- It's incredible.
I call my glam squad, Harry Potter.
I do not look like this. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
I was like, you will see me in Target
and be like, "Wait what?" (laughs)
(audience laughing)
But for Judy you got to
record at Abbey Road, I heard.
- Yes.
- Was that so insane?
- It's crazy.
- Yeah.
- I laugh every day.
- I mean, musicians don't
ever get to do that.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that's really cool.
- Have you been?
- I've been to Abbey Road,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, that was I gonna say,
cause I'm sure that-
- I've never recorded there.
That's amazing.
- It's just a-
- Yeah, it's childhood dream stuff.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, 'cause I don't
know about you guys,
I grew up a big Beatles fan,
and just to go there, and
they like let you in. (laughs)
- And they like let you in? (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, I walk up on the steps
and I laugh 'cause
they're gonna let me in.
Yeah, that was enough,
but then to get to actually go
into some of the studios and lay tracks,
that was crazy.